-Our next guests
are the co-authors
of the political thriller
"State of Terror,"
which is out now.
One is an award-winning
best-selling author,
and the other is a former
senator, secretary of state,
and the winner
of the 2016 popular vote.
Please welcome to the show
Louise Penny
and Hillary Rodham Clinton.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Welcome to the show!
-Real people!
-Real human beings.
-Not bad, right?
Not bad.
Well, we're very -- we're
very lucky to have you both
on a night
that the audience is here.
Congratulations on the book.
-Thank you.
-You've written nonfiction.
Louise, you have
written mysteries.
This is a thriller.
It's a little different
for both of you.
How was your
collaboration process?
-It was fabulous, I have to say.
You know,
Louise and I were friends
before the idea
was presented to us,
and I really came to know her
through her amazing series,
the Gamache series,
that I just loved.
And when the idea was presented,
I think both of us were,
you know, a little --
you know, wondering,
how would this work?
'Cause we were friends.
We didn't want to undermine
our friendship.
And so we dove into it and we
started working on outlines.
-Well, we tried
to figure it out, didn't we?
Like, what are we
going to write about?
And, you know, we thought,
first of all,
if you've got
a secretary of state,
maybe you don't want
to write about
a secretary of transportation.
-Right.
-So that was clear,
but the rest of it wasn't.
-Did you ever say, "You know,
we could also write
about a Canadian
mystery author"?
-Yes, I did!
And Hillary kept nixing it.
-Yeah.
-Classic Hillary.
-That was classic Hillary.
Exactly. Yeah, exactly.
So then there were times
when we were --
because this was
in the pandemic, right?
So we couldn't even
get together.
So we were doing FaceTimes
and, "What about this
and what about that?"
And then there were times
we got ourselves so confused,
we thought each other's screen
had frozen
'cause we were just
staring at each other.
Like, "Where do we go
from here?"
-We had these dreams
before the pandemic
that, you know, we'd meet
at a spa somewhere.
-Sure.
-You know, we'd spa all morning.
-We'd spa all morning.
-Maybe write for an hour.
We'd go back and spa some more.
-Yes, have a facial, exactly.
-None of that --
-You probably got it done faster
this way.
-I think we probably did.
[ Laughs ]
-So, this is about a new
secretary of state who --
and there's also a character
who's a former president
who's reckless.
-You could say that, yeah.
-I think there are other words.
-He's from Palm Beach.
-Well, a lot of people
live in Palm Beach.
-Yeah, a lot of people
live in -- Right, yeah.
But was he inspired by anyone?
Was there anybody in real life?
-He is fictional, Seth.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-He is fictional.
However, having lived through
the prior four years...
-Yeah.
-...it wasn't too hard
to imagine.
-Yeah.
-And the president is someone
who gets the country
into a lot of trouble.
-Yeah.
And some of it of his own making
and some of it because
he doesn't understand
how other bad actors
are actually using him.
You know, so it wasn't
too difficult for, you know,
Louise and I to think about
this fictional former president.
-No.
No, no, no.
But I remember the moment
when I asked you,
like, what -- what
was your nightmare?
When you were
secretary of state,
what kept you awake at night?
-Yeah, yeah.
-And --
-I had a list.
-She had a list.
[ Laughter ]
It was terrifying,
so then she went through it,
and I said, "Well, choose one,"
and you chose
the nuclear option.
-I mean, in the book,
the plot really revolves
around the great fear that
we always had, and still do,
that terrorists would somehow
get ahold of nuclear weapons,
either a dirty bomb
or something more sophisticated,
and it's a plot that we hope
never, ever comes true
in real life.
But it is something
of a cautionary tale
about what could happen.
-When you were
secretary of state,
I imagine briefings
all the time,
and you would have a great
burden, I would imagine, on you
to make sure you were
up to speed on everything.
But it would also,
I would imagine, be important
to find time to, like, shut
your brain down a little bit.
-Right.
-Did you in those times --
Were you reading fiction
about worst-case scenarios,
or were you reading
even lighter stuff?
-Lighter stuff, lighter stuff,
but also classic mysteries,
like the ones
that Louise writes.
You know, and "People"
and "Us Weekly."
I mean, I was trying to keep up
with what was actually
going on in the world,
not just what was
in my briefings.
-Whereas I was reading
intelligence reports.
[ Laughter ]
-I have a lot more questions
for both of you.
We will be right back with more
from Hillary Rodham Clinton
and Louise Penny.